i've just received intel that the
british power grid is failing
there are rolling outages in france
spain germany
[Applause]
something's wrong with the oil andy
system shut down
equipment failure they've never seen
anything like it
i need to do a full analysis
spectroscopy energy density everything
i'll get to the bottom of it
your son is having surgery and i will be
there
i need to do this i don't want you to
leave i'll be back i promise
[Applause]
planes are crushing and no one can see
why
the worst case is unfolding
the sophisticated attacks
everything will be impacted food
medicine electricity leading to mass
panic then violence
you think this is deliberate
chaos is the gravest danger
let's go let's go
your expertise makes you a target
you're not telling me something
there is a lot at stake here i need you
folks i don't know where my wife and
kids are
[Music]
once you've seen the truth
it becomes your responsibility to help
other people's hate too
we're going to do this together every
step of the way
just tell me what i've got to do
you